This parabola will have a vertex at negative 3, negative 4. 3 units left, and 4
units down. We can start from the basic graph y equals x squared. We know that
that vertex is centered at the origin. If we subtract 4 from this equation we
know that the entire parabola shifts down four units. Essentially all the y
values from the original graph that we had before shifted down four units.
Notice to that the y coordinate of the vertex is now negative 4. And we see
this reflected in the equation. We have a negative 4 tacked on to the end. So
we know that the y coordinate of the vertex is negative 4. And to find the x
coordinate of the vertex we take our binomial and we set it equal to 0. Solving
for x will get x is equal to negative 3, the x coordinate of our vertex.